here's how you can earn 23 million
dollars on YouTube and five years in
jail Jose Tehran was sentenced by the
U.S government to 70 months in prison
for running one of the largest royalty
music scams of all time here's how he
did it step one create a fake record
label and then fraudulently claim other
artists songs on YouTube step two hire a
team to search for songs that aren't
being actively monetized so you can
manipulate YouTube's Content ID system
all of this will allow you to submit
your library of stolen songs as
legitimately owned so that you can claim
100 of the monetization and royalties
from the videos that these songs were on
dolla dolla bills y'all